das thema schwarzfahren ist ja
wahrscheinlich vielleicht aber wir
werden erklären
ein kavaliersdelikt es ist sehr nervig
oder oder lohnt es sich zu zocken das
sind so fragen wie sich unsere zuschauer
stellen
fangen wir doch erst mal an ich fahre
schwarz werde erwischt
soll ich dann gleich bezahlen oder soll
ich eher auf die leichte schulter nehmen
nee das ist tatsächlich gar nicht so
ganz ohne
da haben wir nämlich zwei ebenen erst
mal haben wir die zivilrechtliche ebene
da geht es um dieses erhöhte
beförderungsentgelt was dann fällig ist
das sind dann meistens so um die 40 euro
plus eben die verfahrenskosten die dann
entstehen das sind dann auch nochmal so
vielleicht fünf bis zehn euro
das sollte man natürlich schnell
bezahlen damit die sache irgendwie vom
tisch ist und dann kommt aber noch diese
strafrechtliche ebene denn man glaubt es
kaum aber das ist strafbar nach dem
strafgesetzbuch erschleichen von
leistungen heißt das ganze nämlich und
darauf kann bis zu einem jahr
freiheitsstrafe im ernstfall oder eben
ich sag mal so im krassen ausnahmefällen
tatsächlich auch drohen tatsächlich sie
haben es selbst erlebt da gibt es auch
notorische schwarzfahrer die also nie
bezahlen weil sie sagen wie soll ich dem
staat dar was bezahlen was sind meine
erfahrung bei dem thema also wirklich
total verrückt wenn das so ein zweimal
passiert dann werden solche verfahren
bei gericht meistens eingestellt oder
von den staatsanwaltschaften dann zahlt
man den ball
da wird das eingestellt aber ich habe
auch schon pflichtverteidigung vertreten
wo wir wirklich mandanten hatten die
tatsächlich 20 30 40 mal schwarz
gefahren sind
und dann droht tatsächlich auch eine
haftstrafe ganz konkret kann man sich
eigentlich kaum vorstellen eine
haftstrafe weil man irgendwie schwarz
gefahren ist hört sich ein bisschen
absurd an ist aber möglich und deswegen
wird darüber auch immer diskutiert ob
tatsächlich das schwarzfahren in der
straßenbahn oder im bus ob das
tatsächlich strafbar sein muss da gibt's
über massig kritik also im moment ist es
noch strafbar es wird immer wieder
darüber nachgedacht ob man nicht das aus
dem straf rahmen aus rausnehmen sollen
natürlich ist es nicht erlaubt ist klar
war muss es trotzdem bezahlen
aber die frage ist doch muss man da
wirklich noch eine strafe herbeiführen
ist das nicht mit kanonen auf spatzen
geschossen aktuell ist strafbar
mal sehen was die zukunft bringt ein
anderes thema natürlich die leute sagen
mit ich habe vielleicht meine fahrkarte
nicht dabei oder hab sie meine
monatskarte im portmonee mitgewaschen
also ich bin im moment nicht in der lage
diese monatskarte bei der kontrolle
vorzulegen wie gehe ich da am besten vor
man kann das nachlegen man kann also da
durchaus mit den somit den
beförderungsunternehmen sprechen und das
später vorlegen dann wird das verfahren
niedergeschlagen bei der
staatsanwaltschaft dann sowieso
und tatsächlich unsere botschaft
natürlich lieber bezahlen obwohl
vielleicht einige sagen ja ich zocke
lieber und wenn ich dann längere zeit
schwarz gefahren wird dann einmal
erwischt werde dann lohnt sich dann doch
aber davon müssen wir an dieser stelle
abraten oder absolut also die die
konsequenzen die anderen können sind
doch ärgerlich und dann dürfen wir eines
nicht vergessen bei einem
wiederholungsfall dann sind auch
geldstrafen bei gericht möglich
möglichst sogar oberhalb der grenze die
in einem führungszeugnis auftaucht denn
ab 90 tagessätzen aufwärts ist ja ein
eine vorstrafe tauchte im
führungszeugnis auf also ab 91
tagessätzen quasi oder eben drei monate
freiheitsstrafe
und dazu kann es im wiederholungsfall
schon kommen und das wäre doch total
blöd wenn das für soll des hautes nur
weil man eben schwarz fährt und die
meisten städte haben ja auch ein
sozialticket das heißt die wenn man also
die sozialen voraussetzungen erfüllt
dann zahlt man gar nicht den normalen
preis sondern einen günstigeren preis
und zumindest das sollte man dann
zumindest machen